la parole est à Monsieur Johnny jarre
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
économiques et pour 10 minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
président de commission madame la
représentante du président de commission
mais je suis un collègue cette
résolution vise à créer une commission
d'enquête sur le coût de la vie dans les
départements et régions d'outre-mer les
Drôme
je ne m'attarderai pas sur le volet
juridique de la commission d'enquête et
ont été jugés recevable
quant à l'opportunité de créer cette
commission elle est impérieuse et
urgente vous le savez la lutte contre la
vie chère dans nos territoires
d'Outre-mer est un défi majeur pour nos
peuples et nos territoires aussi c'est
l'une des missions quand je porte avec
mes collègues pour et au nom de nos
peuples respectifs dans le respect de la
République
notre approche pour étudier le coût de
la vie dans nos territoires
d'Ultramarins et novatrice car global
elle prend en compte toutes leurs
singularité leur mode de vie marqués par
une assimilation intégrale à travers
notamment des contraintes d'importation
massive de France et d'Europe
cette vision globale portant sur le coût
de la vie permettra d'objectiver
clairement et de mieux comprendre
plusieurs de ses conséquences majeures
la vie chère le faible niveau de vie la
perte d'attractivité particulièrement
manifeste aux Antilles les conditions de
vie dégradées les révoltes sociales de
grande ampleur irrigues
en effet cette vision porte sur le
cocktail des déterminants associés
caractérisant le coût de la vie à
travers un niveau de vie des peuples des
territoires ultramarins très inférieurs
un niveau de prix excessif à
sous-financement des collectivités
locales et un traitement injuste et
inéquitable de l'État vis-à-vis de nos
peuples et de nos territoires
lorsque la population hexagonale souffre
d'une inflation conjoncturelle de près
de 6%, vous dites comprendre ses
souffrances et ses difficultés dans nos
outre-mer et ceux de manière historique
et structurelle l'inflation est en
moyenne supérieure de 40% à celle de
l'Hexagone lorsqu'on y ajoute
l'inflation conjoncturelle nos
territoires se retrouvent au-delà de 45%
aujourd'hui
imaginez donc le niveau de difficulté de
souffrance dans lesquelles se retrouvent
nos peuples captifs et légitimement
exaspéré
pire cette situation menace de donner le
coup de grâce au plus vulnérable et au
plus démunis impuissant face aux
épreuves quotidiennes de la vie et face
à un mal ancien et bien connu la vie
chez l'homme mais chers collègues vous
ne pouvez pas avoir oublié les émeutes
contre la vie chez eux qui ont secoué
nos territoires de manière récurrente
entre 2009 et 2020
aujourd'hui face à la spirale
inflationniste qui vient encore frapper
ses territoires confronté au mal
développement les outre-mer pourraient
de nouveau se transformer en poudrière
sociale
c'est que la vie chère dans les
outre-mer résultat de la conjonction de
moins 4 phénomènes
cet en premier lieu une problématique de
revenus et de niveau de vie en effet
d'après une étude de saisir de la
Réunion la vichère s'expliquerait à 80%
par un problème de revenus et à 20% par
un problème de prix
les revenus et les niveaux de vie sont
inférieurs dans les outre-mer en raison
notamment de taux de pauvreté de
précarité de chômage beaucoup plus élevé
et d'un accroissement des inégalités
il reviendra à la commission d'enquête
d'établir une diagnostic actualisée du
niveau de vie et de revenu en
identifiant les causes de cette
situation dans les territoires
ultramarins tout en proposant des
préconisations et solutions pour y
remédier de plus plusieurs réformes
fiscales ont diminuent plus directement
le pouvoir d'achat des ultramarins ainsi
la commission d'enquête devra
s'intéresser de près à la traque au
niche fiscal et social mené dans les
outre-mer à par l'État qui affaiblit
considérablement les populations et les
entreprises ainsi par exemple quand
l'impôt sur le revenu baisse dans
l'Hexagone il explose dans les doms
réduisant ainsi considérablement et
directement le pouvoir d'achat
elles doivent ainsi proposer des
solutions concrètes pour améliorer sur
ce point le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
la vie chère est en second lieu une
problématique de niveau des prix selon
l'INSEE en 2015 sur les prix dans les
outre-mer on note des écarts criants
pour les produits alimentaires de près
de 40 %
. c'est le cas dans tous les domaines et
particulièrement pour les dépenses
contraintes des ménages des entreprises
associations et collectivités
plusieurs facteurs expliquent ces écarts
de prix majeurs
l'insularité et l'éloignement
géographique avec l'Hexagone induisent
des coups d'approche des biens très
important de même que l'exécuté des
territoires favorise les oligopoles et
réduit la concurrence la commission
d'enquête devra nécessairement porter
ses travaux sur la formation des prix
l'accumulation des marges la
concentration verticale encore plus
particulièrement en mettant en lumière
la consolidation des phénomènes
oligopolistiques et monopolistique
la position déjà dominante de l'amateur
CMA CGM via le fret maritime dans la
décès des Outre-mer va se renforcer avec
la disparition de son concurrent max
après la crise covid il sera nécessaire
de dictionner entre autres la direction
de cette compagnie afin de faire toute
la lumière sous la manière dont ce
dernier décompose précisément ces tarifs
de fret maritime
en troisième lieu on peut également
citer parmi les autres facteurs
responsables indirectement de la vie
chère le sous-financement des
collectivités territoriales ultramarines
un problème pointé par le rapport
patient Cazeneuve de 2019
en effet au sous-financement structurel
s'ajoute un sous-financement conjonctuel
avec l'obligation qui leur était faite
malgré le fait qu'elles étaient déjà
exemples de contribuer au redressement
des comptes publics le recettes ont
ainsi mécaniquement chuté alors que
leurs dépenses elles ont
considérablement augmenté malgré la
reconnaissance par le Président de la
République de ces inégalités la
péréquation mise en place par l'État n'a
que partiellement compensé les pertes de
recettes qu'il avait ponctionné en
cumulé en 9 ans l'État a ainsi réduit de
869 millions d'euros le budget des
communes de ces Dom ce qui après la
hausse de la péréquation génère un
déficit net de près de 400 millions
d'euros en 2022
ne bénéficiant pas du niveau
d'investissement public d'État qu'il
faudrait pour rattraper les retards et
pour répondre mal développement
chronique dont elle souffre leur compte
s'est considérablement dégradé pour
survivre elles n'ont pas eu d'autres
choix que d'augmenter les impôts locaux
et les taxes des ménages et des
entreprises de diminuer le niveau de
service public et d'augmenter le coût
des prestations publiques la commission
d'enquête devrait analyser analyser ce
cercle vicieux qui affaiblit
considérablement l'institution publique
de proximité incapable de jouer son rôle
de régulateur de soupape et d'initiative
ce qui provoque une dégradation du
pouvoir d'achat et des conditions de vie
accroît la pauvreté et le chômage
incitant une fine et les jeunes à l'exil
ou les relega vient d'être trafics en
pleine expansion
cet engrenage ne peut conduire qu'au cas
au social aussi la commission d'enquête
devrait également proposer des solutions
adaptées enfin dans la formation des
prix la fiscalité TVA octobre dans son
ensemble est à prendre en compte pour sa
part de renchérissement du coût de la
vie en effet le poids de la TVA récolté
par l'État est sensiblement égal à celui
récolter au titre de l'octroie de mer la
commission d'enquête au niveau de la
formation des prix devient évaluer le
rôle exact et le poids de chaque élément
de la fiscalité mais aussi son poids
global
elle devrait ainsi dire si l'addition de
l'octroi de mer et la TVA est légale
justifiée et raisonnable dans le rocher
glissement des prix la commission
étudiera ainsi les solutions qui
permettront de résoudre l'équation
associant baisse du coût de la vie et
préservation des moyens d'action des
collectivités en quatrième lieu le
dernier phénomène agissant indirectement
sur la vie chère et le traitement de
l'État inéquitable et injuste vis-à-vis
des territoires ultramarins en effet les
dispositifs nécessaires au soutien de
l'économie et du pouvoir d'achat des
ménages et des entreprises ultra-marines
ont déjà été restreint et pourrait
disparaître afin de réduire le déficit
de l'État ce qui déstabilise les ménages
et les entreprises au détriment de la
cohésion sociale de la production de
l'investissement et de la création
d'emplois par exemple la TVA non perçu
récupérable des entreprises a été
supprimées pour 100 millions d'euros en
2018 par ailleurs l'iniquité de
traitement se traduit particulièrement
sur le montant de la dotation de
continuité territoriale 45 pour 45
millions d'euros pour l'ensemble des
outre-mer et 190 millions d'euros pour
la Corse la commission d'enquête devra
faire la lumière sur l'ensemble de ces
iniquités mesurer leur impact et
proposer des mesures de sauvegarde
d'équité et les solutions globales qui
s'imposent aujourd'hui les instruments
prévus pour lutter contre la vie chère
on le mérite d'exister mais produisent
des effets insuffisants le bouclier
qualité primaire d'être amélioré les
observatoires des prix des marges des
revenus manuellement de moyens pour
fonctionner de plus il manque des
données et statistiques actualisées sous
l'évolution des prix des marges et des
revenus dans les dromes la majorité
d'entre elles datant au mieux de 2019
soit avant la crise sanitaire enfin le
17 mai 2022 l'appel de Fort-de-France
qui a été signé par les présidents des
régions des drones et Saint-Martin un
système notamment sur la refondation de
la relation entre les territoires
ultramarins et la République pour
résoudre concrètement les problèmes
structurels de ces territoires par la
construction et la prise en main de
manière endogène d'outils de moyens de
compétences et de pouvoir le courriel au
cœur de ces préoccupations quotidiennes
se trouvent la question du coût de la
vie dans les dromes la création de cette
commission d'enquête devrait s'inscrire
dans la convergence de l'appel le Fort
de France ainsi que des initiatives en
faveur d'une adaptation des politiques
publiques à venir
cette approche globale est novatrice à
travers la connaissance fine des
caractéristiques du coût de la vie dans
les outre-mer que pourrait établir la
commission d'enquête aura donc des
vertus nombreuses qui dépassent la seule
expression de la charité de la vie en
effet elle permettra fondamentalement de
mieux connaître appréhender évaluer et
prospecter sur les modèles économiques
en vigueur la singularité les
particularités des cultures et identité
de chaque territoire leur sociologie
propre leur enviement leur environnement
propre le but étant de pouvoir asseoir
si le fondement des conclusions de cette
commission d'enquête dans le cadre de la
République et dans le respect de nos
différences des projets au service de
l'intérêt général ouvrons ainsi
l'espérance de véritables perspectives
de développement empreinte d'un idéal
humaniste progressiste et responsable à
cette fin il est nécessaire qu'une
commission d'enquête parlementaire
puisse consacrer à ce sujet brûlant six
mois de travaux effectifs avec des
auditions sous serment des visites et
des contrôles souplesse sur pièce pardon
et sur place aimé ces air dirait
une civilisation qui s'avère incapable
de résoudre les problèmes que suscite
son fonctionnement est une civilisation
décadente une civilisation qui choisit
de fermer les yeux à ses problèmes les
plus cruciaux est une civilisation
atteinte une civilisation qui ruse avec
ses principes est une civilisation
moribonde merci merci monsieur le
rapporteur
la parole est à Monsieur Elie califère
pour le groupe socialiste et apparenté
pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
un triple homercement d'abord à mon
collègue rapporteur
et chef de fil chez Johnny il y a eu le
courage de proposer la création du
commission d'enquête afin de analyser
les mécanismes de formation de prix
remerciement aussi au groupe socialiste
et à parenté qu'une fois encore permet à
cet assemblée trois ans après la
commission d'enquête sur le plan d'icône
de faire la lumière sur un des mots qui
frappe nos populations
un remerciement enfin aux membres de la
commission qui ont voté à l'unanimité
cette proposition de résolution preuve
que le coût exorbitant de la vie en
outre-mer
est désormais reconnu et appelle la
mobilisation de tous Je le reviendrai
pas sur les statistiques édifiant
égrainer avant moi mes forces de
constater que les inégalités persistent
que pour beaucoup même la survie est
inaborable
quand on le sait cela profite de façon
indécente à une certaine
hélas mise à part les annonces
tonitruantes et la communication
effrénée disons même de l'action de
l'inaction à la matière des différents
gouvernants ils ont clairement aussi que
les gouvernements successifs disposent
depuis 2017 de tous les pouvoirs légaux
pour lutter contre la vie chère à notre
mère
régulation des marchés de gros et de la
chaîne logistique définition de prix
global d'un panier de produits de
première nécessité blocage des prix des
carburants aide au fret répression des
accords exclusifs d'importation contrôle
les opérations de concentration tous les
vantails des mesures légales permettant
de réguler la concurrence et de baisser
les prix existent depuis bientôt 10 ans
face aux mécanisme de profitation comme
on dit chez nous qui étouffe nos
compatriotes la loi permet d'ores et
déjà au gouvernement et au-delà du bqp
d'encadrer voire d'administrer les prix
de plafonner les prix des billets
d'avion de baisser les prix les
carburants de saisir l'autorité de la
concurrence sur l'explosion des frites
du prix des fêtes si donc la loi reste
encore améliorable beaucoup dans cette
affaire se résume souvent à une question
de volonté politique je forme donc le
vœu que cette future Commission
d'enquête puisse non seulement faire la
lumière sur les nœud structurelles
contribuant à enrichir à renchérir le
coût de la vie mais formule également
des Pistols légistiques et techniques
d'amélioration de cette situation au
delà de cette au-delà de cette
commission au delà cette commission de
voir aussi à mon sens interrogé le rôle
de l'État
dans ce contexte brûlant et notamment
d'isolant aussi questionner son
désengagement et sont sous
investissement chroniques dans les
infrastructures de base des Outre-mer
le travail investigation qui nous attend
dans les prochains mois sera certes
passionnant mais ardu
sa pertinence et sont sérieux
contribuant à libérer des milliers de
consommateurs qui partout dans tous les
territoires d'outre-mer ne sont ni plus
ni moins que les otages des groupes
oligo-polistiques qui précurent le
pouvoir d'achat et plonge dans la grande
précarité l'ensemble des Outre-mer c'est
la raison pour laquelle dans sa grande
complétude et avec motivation le groupe
socialiste votera cette PPR merci
beaucoup
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Xavier Albertini pour le groupe
horizon et apparenté pour 5 minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur mes
chers collègues la proposition de
résolution tendante à la création d'une
commission d'enquête sur le coût de la
vie dans les départements région
d'outre-mer présenté par les députés du
groupe socialiste et apparentés vise à
étudier l'ensemble des mécanismes qui
concourent au cou de la vie en outre-mer
et c'est important me semble-t-il
d'insister sur les mots l'ensemble des
mécanismes parce que même si nous
arrivons à une conclusion identique avec
le groupe des socialistes et apparenté
sur la nécessité de créer une commission
d'enquête nous regrettons pour notre
part un parti pris d'ores et déjà
affiché dans les orientations je vous
invite donc mes chers collègues à garder
l'esprit clair
d'attendre les auditions et les
déplacements pour arrêter un diagnostic
et non les utiliser pour justifier des
conclusions qui seraient prêt-à-porter
ne gâchons pas cette chance d'avoir les
moyens de procéder à un travail sérieux
et transpartisan dans l'intérêt des
territoires ultramarins le coût de la
vie en outre-mer est plus élevé qu'en
métropole ce n'est pas une découverte et
cela dure depuis des décennies c'est dû
pour partir la distance avec la
métropole à l'exécuter des marchés à la
spécificité insulaire qui part nature
augmente les prix du fait de la
logistique et du transport le phénomène
des hausses des prix a été accentué ces
derniers mois par une conjoncture
mondiale très difficile qu'aux
rapporteur de la mission inflation entre
juillet et décembre 2022 avec ma
collègue Aurélie trouvée nous avons
étudié cette hausse des primes y compris
en outre-mer et constater qu'il n'y
avait pas pour autant de surchauffe
supplémentaires dans ces territoires la
sortie de crise covid les conséquences
des intempéries
et de la grippe aviaire la guerre en
Ukraine et la tension sur les marchés de
l'énergie
tous ces facteurs touchent de manière
identique l'ensemble du territoire
français il n'y a pas d'effet
d'accélération du fait du particularisme
ultramarin pour autant pour autant on ne
peut nier que l'impact sur le pouvoir
d'achat des ultra maliens est plus fort
en lien avec des difficultés
structurelles multiples l'enjeu de cette
commission d'enquête est d'identifier
analyser comprendre aux peupler ces
phénomènes et d'apporter des
préconisations concrètes et
opérationnelles que savons-nous nous
savons que le niveau de vie médian
annuel dans les dromes atteint 17000
euros alors qu'il est de 24000 euros en
Île-de-France et 22.000 euros lycée au
National nous savons que 42% de la
population vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
et que le taux de chômage s'élève à 22%
nous savons que l'illettrisme touche 20%
de la population alors que seulement 7%
dans l'Hexagone nous savons enfin que le
taux de mortalité maternelle sur la
période 2010-2019 est multiplié par 4 et
le taux de naissance mort née multiplié
par 1,5
c'est quelques chiffres en disent long
sur l'importance des chantiers à mettre
en oeuvre dans l'outre-mer pour établir
un cadre de vie plus équilibré dans les
territoires de la République
certes l'essentiel des chantiers se
mènera au très long pardon au très long
cours mais dans l'intervalle il nous
appartient d'apporter des solutions
d'amortissement de soutien la
transformation c'est tout l'intérêt par
exemple de lodino du pouvoir d'achat
déclaré en décembre dernier qui consiste
à redonner du pouvoir d'achat en
étendant le bouclier qualité prix qui
fixe un prix maximum pour un certain
nombre de produits de grandes
consommations c'est tout l'intérêt du
dispositif dédoublement des classes CPE
CP CE1 qui d'ores et déjà porte des
fruits sur la lecture et l'écriture des
enfants c'est tout l'intérêt de
l'investissement massif dans les réseaux
d'assainissement des eaux
cette majorité fait aussi des efforts
sur la forme la décision d'une part
d'adopter un réflexe d'outre-mer visant
adopté chacun des textes en réalité
ultra-marines et d'autre part de voter
des lois répondant des problématiques
spécifiques à ces territoires et la
preuve d'une conscience inédite au sein
du groupe horizon et apparenté nous
abordons cette future Commission
d'enquête parlementaires sereinement
avec la volonté d'être utile et efficace
pour nos concitoyens d'outre-mer mes
chers collègues établissent ensemble une
diagnostic partagée et ce qui sont des
solutions soyons ambitieux pour ces
territoires de la République je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Madame Sabrina c'est Bailly pour le
groupe écologiste et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues
vivre coûte beaucoup mourir également
c'est par cette phrase du poète Jacinto
Louise guerena que je veux commencer mon
propos aujourd'hui cette phrase résonne
bien malheureusement dans notre pays qui
ici ne connaît pas un de ses amis un
membre de sa famille qui n'arrive plus à
s'en sortir de le 5 du mois parfois même
dès que la paie arrive sur le compte en
banque qui ici nous connaît pas un
collègue un proche obligé de s'endetter
parfois de multiples reprises pour payer
un mois de loyers en retard ou une
facture d'électricité qui s'est envolée
ce sont vos choix aujourd'hui chers
collègues de la majorité présidentielle
qui ont amené cette explosion de
précarité financière et sociale dans
notre pays et ce sont encore vos choix
qui aggravent cette situation dans les
territoires ultramarins alors que l'on
constate le taux de chômage un taux de
chômage très élevé à la réunion des
difficultés d'accès à l'eau et à
l'hôpital à la Guadeloupe une crise de
la démographie à Mayotte des
catastrophes écologiques comme les
Sargasses à la Martinique ou encore de
fortes convoitises de ressources
naturelles minières forestière pétrol en
Guyane les départements et régions
d'outre-mer possèdent le point commun de
la Ferté de la vie vous avez abandonné
des territoires et des citoyens de la
République ces territoires où le taux de
chômage est supérieur de 10 points en
rapport à celui de l'Hexagone ces
territoires contaminés au chlore des
cônes ces territoires où le pack d'eau
coûte parfois plus de 10 euros ou un
paquet de riz coûte en moyenne 85 plus
pour cent plus cher et le café 133% de
plus que faites-vous pour ces
territoires mes chers collègues vous
leur envoyez l'armée lorsqu'il manifeste
pour leur survie et leur dignité vous
aggravez leur précarité en
raccourcissant les délais
d'indemnisation au chômage vous
accroissez leurs problématique de santé
en les faisant partir à la retraite deux
ans plus tard
aucune politique ambitieuse n'a été
menée pour réduire la fracture
territoriale entre l'hexagone et les
outre-mer pire vous avez envoyé un
message délétère dès le début de ce
quinquennat en rattachant le ministère
de l'Outre-mer à celui de l'Intérieur
cet abandon et cette gestion sécuritaire
de ces territoires porte un nom c'est
une gestion coloniale où sont les
services publics en outre-mer où est le
service public du logement quand la
majorité des logements sont insalubres
et inadaptés aux événements climatiques
extrêmes qui y sont nombreux où est le
service public de la santé quand les
plus grands déserts médicaux de France
se trouvent en outre-mer où est le
service public de l'emploi quand le taux
de chômage atteint 18% en Guadeloupe
contre 7% en hexagone où est le service
public de justice qu'en 90% des
populations Martini Guess et
Guadeloupéens sont contaminés au
chlordécone et que la justice prononce
un non-lieu
si vous êtes attaché à la devise de
notre République et à l'égalité entre
tous les citoyens alors voter cette
proposition de nos collègues socialistes
oui nous devons ouvrir les yeux et
intervenir sur les mécanismes qui
conduisent à l'explosion des prix dans
ces territoires car le courage c'est de
chercher la vérité et de la dire je vous
remercie merci madame la députée la
parole est à Monsieur Giovanni Williams
démocrate et républicain nu mais pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci merci madame la Présidente sur le
rapporteur
mesdames Messieurs chers collègues
voilà bien 6 études
rapports et mission d'information
restituées par le César par l'Assemblée
nationale par le Sénat mais aussi par
l'Autorité de la concurrence sur les
moyens de résorber la fierté de la vie
dans les territoires dit d'outre-mer
et cela en 2012 en 2017
en 2019 et en 2020
notons chez un collègue
plus de 65 propositions faites par notre
Parlement et par d'autres instances
publiques et administratives pour
réduire la fierté de la vie en outre-mer
en l'espace de 12 ans
de loi sectorielles ont été adoptées en
2012 et en 2017 mettant en place
notamment ce fameux dispositif du
bouclier qualité prix
cinq condamnations financières
prononcées par l'Autorité de la
concurrence
à lire ces chiffres on mesure
parfaitement le déséquilibre on pourrait
presque croire que la Martinique la
Guadeloupe la Guyane Mayotte la Réunion
et la Polynésie
sont des paradis mais des paradis d'un
nouveau genre
tolérés voir organiser par la France et
par la République parce qu'il semblerait
que la distinction soit de mise
aujourd'hui
des paradis financiers où il fait bon
vivre dans un climat d'impunité dans
leur règne de la démesure avec une main
mise et sans faille sur le marché local
mais dans ce paradis nos familles
peinent à boucler leur fin de mois
pendant ce temps nos territoires ont les
taux de pauvreté doublées voire triplés
par rapport à la France hexagonale
en 1946 et donc dans cette période de
République la promesse la promesse d'une
justice sociale et économique nous a été
faite
et en 2023 chez un collègue nous
attendons toujours
c'est donc désormais à nous et lui de la
16e législature de prendre nos
responsabilités
la commission d'enquête que nous
appelons de nos vœux et pour laquelle
nous porterons sa création jusqu'au bout
aura vocation et je l'espère à
s'attaquer au coût de la vie dans sa
dimension la plus large sans
œillères et sans cachotteries ni
entourloupe
pas de langue de bois pas de langue de
bois sur la décomposition des prix pas
de langue de bois sur des situations de
monopole malgré les règles pourtant
connues de tous pas de langue de bois et
pas un énième document bien rangé dans
les fonds des tiroirs
par le biais de cette commission
d'enquête nous nous attaquerons au
monopole sans concession aux pratiques
qui privent non compatriotes de la
possibilité d'accéder au meilleur et à
des prix raisonnables
nous croyons donc que cette commission
d'enquête insufflera un vent d'espoir
face aux mesures ponctuelles accordées
en temps d'inflation nous ne demandons
pas l'aumône
nous ne sommes pas dans la quéande nous
exigeons nous revendiquons et nous irons
jusqu'au bout pour que la justice
sociale et économique soit rendue
oui le groupe GDR va en faveur de cette
proposition de résolution pendant la
création de la commission d'enquête sur
le coup de la vie en outre-mer afin que
cesse la duplicité et toutes les formes
de violences économiques à l'encontre de
nos populations je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur max matiasin pour le groupe
liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoire et pour 5 minutes
bonjour à tous bonjour madame la
Présidente
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
monsieur le rapporteur Johnny
vous l'avez parfaitement expliqué à
propos de la vie chère en outre-mer les
chiffres parlent de même il pèsent
d'autant plus sur le pouvoir d'achat de
nos concitoyens ultramarins que au
niveau de vie est inférieur à celui des
hexagonaux selon les dernières
statistiques de l'INSEE par exemple en
Guadeloupe
ce sont ce 34% des personnes qui vivent
sur le seuil de pauvreté contre 14% en
France hexagonale et 12% de nos
concitoyens sont en situation de grande
pauvreté contre 3% dans l'Hexagone et
nos concitoyens de Mayotte souffrent
davantage encore de la pauvreté ce que
je déplore a ici à l'Assemblée nationale
depuis 6 ans alors que tous les députés
ultramarins parlent d'une foi unanime
c'est que nous restions et compris enfin
toute la ciné pression que je garde de
du gouvernement et de la majorité
présidentielle la France ce sont tous
ces territoires la Bretagne la Corse la
Marne et les territoires dit ultramarins
ces territoires qui ont connu à un
moment de leur histoire un régime
politique économique que l'on dit
économie de comptoir basé sur des
préjugés d'inégalités entre les êtres
humains au nom duquel on pouvait
extraire spolier et toutes les richesses
possibles c'est ce que je voudrais que
nous comprenions ces inégalités basées
sur des préjugés et certains prismes au
persisté après la départementalisation
avec par exemple un SMIC qui n'a été
appliqué au même niveau dans l'Hexagone
que très tardivement et je ne parle même
pas de la situation de Mayotte je
reviens dessus qui laisse nos
concitoyens mahorés dans une exigence
scandaleuse c'est la raison pour
laquelle monsieur le rapporteur chez au
collègue lorsque vous préconisez et que
votre groupe soutient cette demande de
commission d'enquête je suis pour le
groupe lot liberté et dépendant
outre-mer et territoire et pour c'est
aussi parce que la commission d'enquête
sur l'eau avec nos excellents collègues
Mathilde panot et Olivier Servat nous a
permis véritablement de faire éclater la
vérité et d'avancer
la commission d'athlète sur le Cloud
icône avec nos noms moins excellent
ancien collègue chimie et Justine Bénin
a permis de faire la lumière et bien des
avancées sur la lutte contre le
cloudicone seul la commission d'enquête
s'est prérogative qui imposent aux
personnes convoquées de déposer sous
serment qui autorise le rapporteur à
exercer un contrôle sur pièce sur place
et à se faire communiquer tout document
utile qui l'autorise également à
demander à la Cour des comptes de
procédés à des enquêtes nous permettra
de mettre en évidence les différents
facteurs concourants à la vie chère et
de faire des propositions pour y
remédier et orienter les politiques
publiques nous pourrons analyser la
formation des prix et des marges de
produits alimentaires le rôle de la TVA
de le croire le poids des oligopoles des
industries des importateurs des
distributeurs du fret etc nous pourrons
aussi évaluer le de l'activité des
différents boucliers qualités prix mise
en oeuvre actuellement par les
différents les différents gouvernements
d'outre-mer analyse du ministère des
Outre-mer analyser la pertinence et les
énergies à des familles de produits le
premier nécessité comme les pâtes ou les
conserves nous pouvons également
examiner la façon dont sont les percuté
sur la consommation les consommateurs
les différentes mesures en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat comme la diminution de
500 euros par conteneur de 40 pieds du
groupe
CMA CGM et en plus du gel des frais
depuis du taux des frais depuis mai 2021
nous n'oublions pas les frais liés les
placements que ce soit les prix du
billet d'avion et de l'essence et du
Logement je rappelle que c'est mon
groupe qui a permis le plafonnement de
la mise à jour annuelle
de la mise à jour annuelle des valeurs
locatives foncières à 2,5% dans le dans
les outre-mer au lieu de 3,5% dans
l'Hexagone nous pourrons mettre en
valeur la nécessité d'expliquer le
principe de différenciation aux
politiques publiques pour permettre
enfin aux économies aux économies de nos
territoires de converger vers
l'autonomie alimentaire et l'autonomie
énergétique avec la géothermie notamment
le tendre vers de plus de justice
économique et sociales c'est pourquoi je
vous le dis à nouveau le groupe iode est
favorable à la mise en place de cette
commission d'enquête sous le coût de la
vie dans les départements et régions
outre-mer
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur Guillaume vuité pour le groupe
Renaissance et pour 5 minutes
madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
nous sommes ici réunis pour pouvoir
examiner la proposition de résolution du
groupe socialiste sur le coût de la vie
en outre-mer c'est une formule qui est
originale puisque les mêmes évidemment
autorisés par notre règlement la
tradition veut que les commissions
d'enquête soient plutôt de l'initiative
des groupes dans le cadre du droit de
tirage c'est un terme qui n'est pas
forcément très heureux mais c'est comme
ça qu'on le fait mais je crois que si le
groupe socialiste a souhaité que ce soit
sous cette forme là c'est parce qu'il
voulait donner une importance toute
particulière à sa démarche et au travers
même de ce premier débat nous rendre
sensible à la réalité de ce qu'elle coût
de la vie en outre-mer
et le constat ne demande pas en la
matière de faux semblant la situation
est particulièrement sensible et vous
aviez raison monsieur le rapporteur de
souligner que nous ne sommes pas dans
une simple montre dans une compétition
de chiffres mais qui viennent réalité
humaine aujourd'hui sur ces territoires
qui fait que la situation peut à tout
moment déraper aussi et aboutir à des
problèmes qui ne sont pas simplement des
problèmes économiques mais même d'ordre
public parce que en effet le nombre de
concitoyens vivent une situation
complexe nous avions eu l'occasion lors
d'un de la semaine de contrôle du
gouvernement il y a peu de souligner son
d'aberration par exemple j'avais pu
rappeler que le prix des loyers dans le
centre de ville en outre-mer était
l'équivalent des grandes métropoles de
l'Hexagone alors même que nous étions
dans la situation économique très
différentes non seulement parce que il y
avait dans nos dans nos villes
hexagonales des services un peu
différents mais aussi simplement parce
qu'il y avait un écart avec le niveau
des revenus ça m'entraîne débattre des
retraites et je signalais il y a peu que
les retraites moyennes à Mayotte c'est
300 euros les moyens les retraites
moyennes en outre-mer c'est 700 euros
évidemment il y a un effet de ciseaux
entre des prix qui sont quasiment 40%
plus cher en outre-mer et ce niveau de
revenus dit qu'il est extrêmement faible
non il faut pas retirer les réformes il
faut l'améliorer c'est d'ailleurs pour
cela qu'avec ma collègue Estelle
Youssoupha qui est ici nous avons déposé
un amendement de façon à pouvoir
accélérer les rattrapages en matière des
retraites à Mayotte en particulier et
qui a un travail à faire sur cela mais
d'abord un travail à faire et c'est pour
ça que je trouve que cette commission
d'enquête est tout à fait légitime mais
qu'évidemment nous la soutiendrons il y
a d'abord un travail à faire pour
comprendre comment c'est pris se sont
formés comme on arrive à de tels
dérapages alors si nous avons une
volonté commune de d'expliquer tout cela
il y a aussi un des attendus et des
considérant dans votre démarche qui
naturellement amène quelques
commentaires j'ai bien remarqué et vous
avez des propos que vous êtes nuls en
commission était très mesurés dans la
matière que vous faisiez de constat que
les défaillances de voltics publics ne
dataient pas de ce gouvernement mais
vous me motorisez quand même à essayer
de le de le soutenir et de soutenir son
action en particulier dans le fait que
par exemple quand Éric cabaret et je le
dis avec beaucoup de respect pour les
cabarites étaient en charge les
outre-mer au sein du gouvernement de
l'époque elle se réjouissait que nous
aboutissions un budget de 2 milliards
d'euros pour l'émission d'outre-mer nous
sommes aujourd'hui à près de 2,8
milliards d'euros donc une progression
considérable 21 milliards de crédits
transversaux qui sont consacrés ces
territoires cela veut pas dire que tout
soit bien et que nous ayons fait un
effort suffisant mais en tout cas ils
viennent pas de rattrapage qui est mené
et si j'entends notre collègue califère
dire qu'il y a des politiques enfin des
outils petits qui existent aujourd'hui
pour lutter contre la richesse c'était
vrai aussi avant et le bouclier prix est
un bouquet qui a été créé un petit peu
avant nous avons renforcé donc nous
sommes bien face à une politique qui est
complexe amener et qui doit être à mon
avis faire l'objet de consensus beaucoup
plus fort
il y a des choses qui se font parce que
nous avons donc le démarche de la vie
chère nous avons mené des conditions
d'enquête dans cette dans cette disciple
pour pouvoir aboutir sur des politiques
en matière de lutte contre les Sargasses
sur le Cloud le soutien à la Guyane le
soutien aussi à la reconstitution d'une
offre de l'eau en Guadeloupe qui est
bien défaillant mais donc évitons les
caricatures pour faire en sorte de
stigmatiser tel ou tel et travaillons
ensemble parce que oui il est nécessaire
absolument de pouvoir reconstituer le
mécanisme de formation des prix de
compense quel poids de l'histoire il est
économie qui fut en effet une économie
coloniale et qui n'a pas achevé sa
transformation de ce qui est le poids
des monopoles et les avis de position
dominante dans la formation du prix ce
qui est le poids aussi de la fiscalité
et des difficultés qui vont avec
le pense d'autant plus que s'il y a
aussi une partie de l'économie
ultramarine qui nous font comprendre
dans cette formation mépris et dans les
effets de ces prix élevés et je pense à
l'économie informelle qui devrait à mon
avis là aussi être
l'objet d'une partie de notre travail
nous avons une commission d'enquête une
commission d'enquête son propre c'est
d'avoir un travail exigeant avec des
personnes qui déposent sous serment mais
c'est aussi une exigence pour nous-mêmes
de ne pas conclure avant d'avoir
commencé nos travaux et je pense que
nous aurons tous le souhait d'aboutir à
des propositions efficaces pour
améliorer la situation de nos
territoires je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député
la parole est à Madame Hélène Laporte
pour le groupe rassemblement national et
pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues la
République reconnaît au sein du peuple
français les populations d'outre-mer
dans un idéal commun de liberté
d'égalité de fraternité c'est au cœur
même de notre Constitution dont je viens
de citer l'article 72 alinéa 3 que
s'inscrit l'exigence de considérer les 3
millions de concitoyens de nos
collectivités ultramarines sur un pied
de stricte égalité avec ceux de la
métropole tout en adaptant leur
traitement aux particularités
qu'imposent l'éloignement géographique
et le cas échéant l'insularité
[Musique]
73% des Martiniquais des guadeloupes des
Guyanais des Réunionnais et 85% des
mahorets ne sont ne sont pas
contribuables les probablement pas
l'exemple le mieux choisi pour illustrer
l'impact des décisions budgétaires sur
le niveau de vie des classes populaires
ultramarines les fortes réductions des
allègements de cotisation sociale pour
les indépendants et de la possibilité
pour les entreprises de récupérer de la
TVA non perçue en arrondissant les
charges pesant sur l'activité économique
on part définition aggraver la situation
des locaux
parallèlement l'octroi de mer a pour
vocation première de protéger la
production agricole artisanale
industriel département d'outre-mer il
constitue également une source majeure
de recettes pour ses collectivités
territoriales aussi sa suppression au
profit d'une TVA à 20% serait évidemment
une décision catastrophique pour notre
part nous soutenons une réforme de
l'octroi en fin d'en exclure les biens
produits en France dans l'Union
européenne qui n’entrera en concurrence
avec aucun bien produit dans les cinq
départements d'outre-mer ainsi il
remplirait sa fonction de protection de
la production ultramarine sans apporter
de dégradation excessive du pouvoir
d'achat des habitants
dans la rédaction actuelle de ce texte
la compétence de la commission d'enquête
porte exclusivement sur les départements
et régions d'outre-mer sur ce point qui
représentait une injustice manifeste
pour les habitants des autres
collectivités territoriales ultramarines
concernée par les mêmes problématiques
d'éloignement et d'insularité nous
saluons la décision de la Commission
d'étendre la portée de cette résolution
au collectivités d'outre-mer régies par
l'article 74 de notre Constitution mais
si ces amendements représentent un
progrès indéniable ils mettent
assistement de côté la
Nouvelle-Calédonie dans le statut
spécial et régi par le titre 13 de notre
Constitution fort d'une population de
plus de 270 000 habitants l'archipel qui
a subi une inflation considérable durant
l'année 2022 doit être étudié au même
titre que les autres collectivités
ultramarines par la future Commission
d'enquête
enfin je voudrais formuler un espoir
celui que la réflexion que nous initions
aujourd'hui sur la situation de nos
territoires ultramarins ne se limitent
pas à la question évidemment centrale du
pouvoir d'achat mais la politique
d'abandon de ces collectivités est à
interroger dans sa globalité car ses
effets se mesurent aussi en matière de
santé publique de lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière ou encore
d'éducation tous ces sujets mériteront à
leur tour des bas public si nous n'avons
pas le courage d'aborder dans chacune de
ces dimensions la gravité que nous avons
laissé s'installer en outre-mer la
défiance de nos concitoyens ne fera que
s'accentuer au risque d'un véritable
divorce politique qui risquerait
irréversiblement de blesser notre unité
nationale aussi dans l'espoir d'un débat
fructueux sur la revalorisation de nos
collectivités ultramarines le groupe
rassemblement national votre résolution
je vous remercie
merci madame la députée la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Luc gratenon pour le
groupe la France insoumise nue et pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues
permettez-moi avant toute chose de
saluer les membres de la commission des
affaires économiques qui ont validé
cette PPA pendant la création d'une
commission d'enquête chargée d'étudier
d'évaluer l'ensemble des mécanismes qui
concourent au cours de la vie dans les
départements région d'outre-mer de mon
collègue je n'y a Charles du groupe
socialiste mais aussi ça lui
l'engagement de tous les consignataires
des autres groupes et les remercier
d'avoir validé en commission en
intégrant l'amendement unique que j'ai
proposé qui élargit le périmètre de la
commission d'enquête aux solutions
possibles afin de remédier à la vie
chère je souhaite à présent que
l'hémicycle vote ce texte compte tenu de
la situation dans nos pays français de
l'Atlantique de l'océan Indien et du
Pacifique et au vu de la situation
l'unanimité l'unanimité doit se faire
par une voie ne doit manquer dans cette
émission en effet
cette PPA est l'occasion de rappeler les
multiples inégalités qui persistent et
s'aggravent dans les fonces non
hexagonaux les taux de pauvreté le
chômage de masse le niveau de vie médian
qui est inférieur de 20 à 23 poissons
Martinique et Guadeloupe à la Réunion il
est inférieur d'un trianguyant de moitié
et à Mayotte il ne représente qu'un
sixième de la valeur hexagonale les prix
des produits alimentaires sont de plus
en plus hors de prix l'accès Internet et
largement plus élevé les fournitures
scolaires sont largement plus chers et
pour prendre quelques exemples il est il
n'est pas normal que le lait en poudre
troisième âge coûte dans des grandes
surfaces à Ivry Sur Scène 10,89 € et à
la Réunion en 14 et 15 euros 59 soit 40%
plus cher jusqu'à plus de 45% sur les
500 g de le paquet de lames de rasoir
pour homme plus de 100% plus cher le
paquet de 10 protection hygiénique 60%
plus cher le pack de DIY coûte jusqu'à
75 % plus cher chez nous à la Réunion
les situations de monopole et
d'oligopole l'éloignement géographique
entre autres ils sont certainement pour
quelque chose les rangs de situations
les abus aussi et surtout à mon sens et
nous avons tous que c'est la même chose
dans tous les autres territoires il
n'est pas normal aussi que les matériaux
de bricolage de construction soit 50 à
80% plus cher les billets d'avion
42% plus cher pour réunion métropole les
colis postaux plus de 20% en plus des
taxes abusives et conviendra pas
conséquent que la commission d'enquête
exige la communication des marges de
tous les acteurs et de toutes les
filières la vérité doit être dite et la
question des revenus est indissociable à
celle du pouvoir d'achat d'autant que
les salaires dans le privé sont 20
poissons inférieurs à ceux de métropoles
oui il n'est pas normal que de plus en
plus de gens n'arrivent plus à se
nourrir correctement il n'est pas normal
que les personnes âgées soient obligées
de se contenter d'avaler un yaourt avant
d'aller de se coucher il n'est pas
normal que des familles invitent leurs
enfants à bien manger à l'école le midi
parce que le soir à la maison le repas
n'est pas équilibré voire insuffisant
voilà quelques vérités de nos
territoires et c'est grave d'autant plus
grave que Total énergie vient d'annoncer
un bénéfice net de 19,5 milliards
d'euros en 2022
une augmentation de 28% par rapport à
2021 le bénéfice le plus important de
toute l'histoire de la multinationale
est l'un des meilleurs du CAC 40
totalement indécent les riches
continuent de se gaver de faire des
super profits que le gouvernement refuse
de taxer alors que dans le même temps
que dans le même temps une grande partie
de la population
s'appauvrit crève la dalle de plus en
plus chaque jour j'avais aussi proposé
un texte dans la niche de mon groupe la
fi le 24 novembre de l'année dernière la
proposition visa assurer l'égalité
effective entre tous les citoyens mais
malheureusement l'obstruction n'a pas
permis de l'examiner aussi cette PPA que
nous examinons aujourd'hui est une
chance de remettre les projecteurs sur
les prises scandaleux en outre-mer et
d'apporter les solutions toute la vérité
rien que la vérité
et ce sera le travail de cette
commission d'enquête la FX dit oui oui
et oui je vous remercie merci monsieur
le député
la parole est à Monsieur Mansour
camardine pour le groupe les
républicains et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
madame la Présidente de la Commission
monsieur le rapporteur très cher
collègue
en déplacement en Guyane le 28 octobre
2017 le président de la République
reconnaît dans un discours prononcé à
l'occasion des Assises de loutre-mer
qui est la vie chère et là une
explication parfois géographique ou
d'organisation quand il faut importer
des matériels des denrées qui viennent
de plusieurs milliers de kilomètres donc
on va lutter contre ça en développant la
souveraineté alimentaire
énergétique de nos territoires mais la
vie disait-il cher et elle aussi
entretenue sur les territoires parfois
par des acteurs économiques qui parce
qu'ils sont en situation de monopole
font payer 5 fois 10 fois les prix de ce
qui serait normal parce qu'ils sont là
je vous le dis et donc l'autorité de la
concurrence l'ensemble des services de
l'État compétent en particulier la
DGCCRF les douanes y aideront aussi se
déploie se déploiront avec force pour
rétablir l'ordre public économique parce
qu'on ne peut pas laisser s'installer
des situations qu'on accepterait dans
aucun territoire de l'Hexagone
c'est-à-dire de
quelques-uns s'enrichissent beaucoup en
entretenant la vie chère pour le reste
de la population des sites le président
de la République vous pouvez applaudir
le Président de la République quand même
lors de l'examen de cette
résolution commission chef président de
la Commission de président des affaires
économiques
a reconnu que cette situation
extrêmement importante à donner lieu à
une abondante de production au sein du
Parlement et en dehors donc un avis de
l'Autorité de la concurrence en juillet
2019 une étude du Conseil économique et
social environnemental en octobre 2020
une enquête de l'INSEE engagée en 2022
et encore en cours le rapport de
Mesdames petit Maïna et RIAC en 2019 un
rapport de la délégation outre-mer
rédigé par les naïc Adam claire Guillon
ferment en décembre 2020 le dernier
rapport conclut-il
sur la question date donc de deux ans
c'est dit que le problème de la vie
chère outre-mer est une donnée connue de
tous mais sur sur laquelle tout le monde
tourne son regard pour paraphraser le
président Jacques Chirac
l'outre-mer sombre dans la pauvreté mais
ne regardons ailleurs nos collègues a eu
la pertinence et l'intelligence de
s'attarder sur cette question et de nous
proposer cette solution de création
d'une commission d'enquête sur la vie
chère dans le département et région
d'outre-mer pour ceux qui concerne
Mayotte
nous nous trouvons nous y trouvons les
déterminants structurels de la sûreté de
la vie économique évoquée dans l'exposé
des motifs de la proportion de
résolution des revenus beaucoup plus
faibles qu'à métropole pour mémoire les
SMIC à Mayotte est inférieur à 20 % de
20 % au SMIC national la pension de
retraite moyenne et de 276 euros des
prix des biens fortement plus élevés que
dans l'Hexagone en particulier en ce
conseil les produits alimentaires qui
des surcroît ont subi une inflation de
29% sur un an des dotations
collectivités clairement inférieures à
celle des droits communs notamment en
raison d'un calcul de la population
Insee inférieure de 30% de la population
réelle s'ajoutent à cela une spécificité
qu'on ne retrouve dans les départements
d'outre-mer camaïeuh l'absence des
statues de Grand Port Maritime pour le
port de lingoni pour qui est de fête
privatisée par une entreprise qui masque
ses comptes à la collectivité
départementale et applique des tarifs
sur de base dans la légalité interroge
jusqu'à la Cour des comptes bien
évidemment cette situation engendre une
importante corruption qui met en péril
tant la démocratie locale que le
développement économique et social du
sang itinéen département à cet égard
l'immobilisme du bras séculier de l'État
mérite d'être examiné mes chers
collègues à Mayotte à chaque élection
l'argent venu de l'angonie à la
barbeonnée du procureur de la République
se répand comme un cancer qui pour faire
élire un tel qui pour faire battre tel
autre au final à travers des prix qui
gonflent au fur et à mesure sur
l'ensemble de la chaîne de valeur c'est
le consommateur final qui paye
l'addition
aussi je vais dire sans détour qu'en
tant que député de Mayotte mais
également en tant que député LR et sur
les recommandations de notre
présidentioti merlex le groupe LR
s'associe complètement cette démarche
aussi bien en ce qui concerne la
cosignature de ce projet de résolution
qu'en ce qui concerne son adoption c'est
la raison pour laquelle les élus LR de
la délégation outre-mer nos collègues
Philippe Gosselin Marc le fuel origin
Pradier ont accepté de consigner le
projet suite à votre aimable invitation
chez rapporteur nous voterons donc sa
réserve cette résolution avec l'espoir
d'une part qu'elle ira jusqu'au bout de
ses investigations pour ensuite formuler
des propositions et d'autre part nous
nous retrouverons tous pour apporter des
solutions efficaces pérennes aux
difficultés de nos concitoyens
ultramarins je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Madame Maud petit pour
le groupe démocrate c'est pour 5 minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur cher Johnny mes chers
collègues comme je l'ai indiqué en
commission la semaine dernière c'est une
nécessité de mettre en lumière
aujourd'hui au sein de notre hémicycle
une problématique majeure de notre pays
et qui pourtant passe trop souvent sous
les radars des médias et des politiques
hexagonales le coût de la vie dans la
France
ultramarine je salue donc l'initiative
de notre collègue Johnny Hajar qui remet
en lumière cette question récurrente et
pour laquelle un aboutissement est
devenu crucial parce que la vie chère
dans les territoires d'outre-mer est une
longue et lourde réalité en 2018 le
niveau de vie médian le plus élevé aux
Antilles à la Réunion et de 17000 euros
il est de 24000 euros en Île-de-France
la dernière enquête économique de
l'Institut de la statistique de la
Polynésie française révélait que les
prix sur le territoire étaient
supérieurs de 39% à ceux hexagone
ce sont les produits alimentaires qui
sont principalement impactés par ces
écarts de prix rendez-vous compte selon
l'Insee se différencier par rapport à
l'Hexagone s'élève à plus de 37% à la
Réunion plus de 42% en Guadeloupe plus
de 45% en Guyane et à temps même plus de
48% en Martinique dans un rapport remis
à la délégation outre-mer en 2019 nos
collègues Lénaïc Adam et claires Guillon
Firmin rappelait l'importance de cette
catégorie de dépenses alimentaires pour
les ménages 16 à 17% des dépenses de
consommation et jusqu'à 24% à Mayotte
c'est énorme quand il s'agit de se
nourrir et comme les exemples sont plus
parlants que les longs discours en voici
quelques-uns un paquet de café solubles
de 200 g 2 fois plus cher en Martinique
il est de 10 euros 62 au Lamentin contre
4 euros 24 au Havre des yaourts par 4
1,37 euros à Paris contre 2,95 euros en
Guadeloupe un kilo de pommes de terre en
Polynésie
ce kilo coûte actuellement plus de 4
euros contre un euro 80 en hexagone et
comptez plus de 5,4 le kilo de bananes
en Nouvelle-Calédonie contre deux euro
en moyenne ici la vie chère en outre-mer
tellement flagrante que la Cour des
comptes a également dénoncé en 2017 un
traitement inéquitable des dômes sur le
plan de la péréquation nationale et ce
traitement défavorable a été reconnu par
le Président de la République en 2019
l'inflation que nous subissons
aujourd'hui actuellement sur notre
continent aggrave une situation déjà
difficilement supportable pour nos
concitoyens ultramarins alors des
rapports ont été rédigés les élus les
parlementaires que nous sommes ont
alerté j'ai moi-même lors d'un rapport
commis en 2019 à mes collègues josette
Manin et Cécile relac déplorait le coup
de la vie en outre-mer source de
discrimination
ces appels ont parfois été entendus des
mesures ont souvent ont été prises et
notre majorité on a pleinement pris la
mesure notamment avec la mise en oeuvre
des Assises des Outre-mer en 2017 et
2018 qui a donné lieu à la rédaction du
livre bleu des Outre-mer
aujourd'hui cependant il reste que
beaucoup pas faire c'est pourquoi le
groupe démocrate soutient totalement la
création de cette commission d'enquête
sur la vie chère en outre-mer qui aura
pour vocation d'analyser les raisons
multiples de ces prix exorbitants dans
ces collectivités ultramarines et devra
cette impératif proposé des solutions
pérennes pour enrayer cette situation
qui n'a que trop duré
fortement attaché au territoire le
groupe démocrate souhaite toutefois que
les collectivités d'outre-mer face
partie intégrale du dispositif ce qui
n'est pas actuellement le cas et c'est
pourquoi je suis heureuse qu'après
plusieurs échanges avec vous monsieur le
rapporteur nous ayons pu vous convaincre
du bien fondé de notre démarche
collectivité régie par l'article 73 et
par l'article 74 de la Constitution
souffre en effet du même mal
chaque terre d'outre-mer possède son
caractère riche et ses spécificités nous
serons donc à vos côtés pour que une
fois les causes établies les solutions à
apporter soit donc adaptées
mes chers collègues je vous le dis mais
je crois que vous en avez déjà
conscience notre union est nécessaire et
indispensable sur ce sujet loin des jeux
politiques notre exemplarité notre
rigueur en tant qu’élu de la République
sont indispensables nos concitoyens de
l'archipel France attend des résultats
concrets palpable sur ce sujet récurrent
et discriminant et notre devoir
maintenant et de réussir enfin à y
mettre un terme je vous remercie
merci Madame la dégoûtée la parole est à
Monsieur philippe Maillet pour le groupe
socialiste qui apparenté pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
la présidente madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
Messieurs chers collègues je voudrais
d'abord bien sûr saluer l'initiative du
collègue Johnny Hajar notre rapporteur
remercier notre groupe le groupe
socialiste d'avoir inscrit cette
proposition de résolution d'une
commission d'enquête sur la vie chère
dans les autres mers dans cette sa
journée d'initiative parlementaire merci
mes chers collègues mesdames messieurs
la vie chère en outre-mer et maintenant
dur maintenant depuis trop longtemps
depuis trop longtemps en notre mère et
c'est perçu par les populations de nos
territoires comme l'une terrible
injustice contre laquelle nous ne
pouvons lutter
non à la Réunion ça a été dit mais je le
rappelle quand même pour certains qui ne
le savent pas qui ne le sauraient pas
sans tomber dans un misérabilisme
quelconque nous subissons la double
peine la double peine c'est quoi ça a
été dit les prix sont plus chers dans
l'alimentation 30% plus cher que dans
l'Hexagone
les prix en général 7% plus cher la
double peine parce que dans le même
temps nous avons deux fois et demi plus
de population qui vit en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté voilà la réalité de
nos territoires aujourd'hui et si on
pose ce problème là ce n'est pas pour
quémander c'est pour corriger les choses
parce que la cherté de la vie est une
injustice que les Réunionnais ne
supportent plus quelqu'un a rappelé je
crois que c'est le collègue mathiasien
il a rappelé que nous avions attendu un
certain nombre d'années pour avoir
l'égalité du SMIC je vais être un peu
plus précis si me permet nous sommes
devenus département français en 1946
nous avons eu l'égalité du SMIC 50 ans
après en 1996 les Réunionnais
n'accepteront pas comprennent encore 50
ans pour faire reculer la vie chère sur
nos territoires
et lorsque et lorsque je dis cela je
voudrais rappeler ici également deux
choses je voudrais rappeler que on parle
souvent des difficultés des fins de mois
pour les familles nous à la Réunion
c'est pas les fins de moi le problème
c'est les débuts de moi une enquête
récente de l'Insee de 2017 elle est pas
très vieille de 2017 montre que pour les
familles les plus modestes la part des
dépenses contraintes c'est 37% des
ressources des familles ça veut dire
qu'en début de mois déjà les familles
réunionnaises ont la tête sous l'eau en
2021 les chiffres sont pas les chiffres
du Parti socialiste ce sont pas les
chiffres de la nupesse ce sont les
chiffres de la Croix Rouge en 2021 dans
un département français le département
de La Réunion une famille réunionnaise
sur 10 a eu recours à un colis
alimentaire voilà la réalité sociale de
notre territoire voilà la réalité de la
Ferté de la vie à la Réunion alors après
avoir dit tout cela il faut préciser
qu'un certain nombre de choses ont été
faites c'est vrai le bouclier qualité
prix est une réalité
l'observatoire des prix des marges de
revenus est une réalité sauf que
l'observatoire des prix des marges des
revenus n'a pas suffisamment de moyens
pour faire son travail aujourd'hui le
décret fixant le coup sur les carburants
est une réalité mais il faut aller plus
loin il faut s'interroger aujourd'hui
sur le rôle des oligopoles et des
monopoles dans la grande distribution il
faut s'interroger sur la constitution
des marges il faut s'interroger
également sur le rôle
sur le rôle des grossistes importateurs
il faut s'interroger sur le rôle de CGA
CGM qui aujourd'hui a le monopole dans
le transport maritime
et quand je dis cela et quand je dis
cela c'est pas parce que je suis obsédé
par CGA CGM c'est pas parce que je passe
mes nuits à rêver de CGA CGM c'est la
réalité un journal local rappelé que en
une année un container de 40 pieds qui
coûtaient à une entreprise entre 1500 et
2000 euros est passé à 7000 euros il
faut s'interroger également sur le prix
des billets d'avion j'entends certains
me dire parfois j'entends certains me
dire parfois mais tu sais
c'est un secteur économique qui est
compliqué les prises augmente partout
dans le monde sauf que nous à la Réunion
sauf que nous à la Réunion pour faire
Saint-Denis Paris Saint-Denis Marseille
Saint-Denis Brest Saint-Denis Angoulême
on ne peut pas venir en bus on ne peut
pas venir en trottinette nous sommes
obligés de prendre l'avion et le prix
d'un billet d'avion en moyenne en
économique vous devez le savoir mes
collègues c'est 2000 euros voilà la
réalité et sur le prix des billets
d'avion je le dis ici même sur un projet
de résolution il n'y a pas de demande de
gouvernement je le dis si l'État a un
rôle à jouer sur le prix des billets
d'avion pour les populations
ultramarines merci monsieur le député
madame la Présidente je dis juste un mot
pour dire que je termine deux mots si
vous me permettez d'abord au collègues
vulte et il a dit il faut pas
caricaturer et lui il a fait quelque
part en disant que dans le projet de loi
de réforme de la retraite il y avait des
mesures pour nous non il n'y a rien dans
ce pro ce projet de loi pour les petits
retraités réunionnais les retraités les
plus pauvres de France Merci monsieur le
député
la parole est à Madame Emmanuelle Ménard
pour les non inscrits pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues
c'est un champ deal déployé sur trois
océans
tourmentés par des meutes de vent par
achevés par une nature sauvage presque
originelle
sur leur côte dans leur lagon au sommet
de leur montagne de leur volcan dans les
creux de leur plaine se cachent une
faune et une flore digne de l'Éden les
traditions y sont légion et les coutumes
innombrables elles ont leur art de vivre
leur culture leur identité leur
spécificités aussi mais toute son
française
des îles françaises qu'il faut le dire
se sentent délaissés abandonnés si leur
cadre de vie est idyllique leurs
conditions de vie le sont beaucoup moins
comme souvent les chiffres parlent
d'eux-mêmes selon une enquête de l'INSEE
une pauvreté plus marquée dans les doms
datant de juillet 2020 le niveau de vie
médian de la population des départements
ultramarins et moins élevé qu'en
hexagone le taux de pauvreté calculé
selon le seuil national et de 34% en
Guadeloupe 33% en Martinique 42% à la
Réunion
53% en Guyane et attend même 77% à
Mayotte contre 14% dans l'Hexagone
toujours selon l'Insee mais cette
fois-ci selon une étude de 2015 les prix
dans les départements ultramarins
s'avèrent plus élevés que dans
l'Hexagone de 12% aux Antilles de 11,7%
en Guyane et de 7% à la Réunion et à
Mayotte l'écart de prix provient
majoritairement des prix des produits
alimentaires ce différentiel par rapport
à l'Hexagone s'élève à plus de 37% à la
Réunion 42% en Guadeloupe 45% en Guyane
et atteint même 48% en Martinique et 64%
à Mayotte
des écarts qui s'expliquent par la
grande dépendance des territoires
outre-marins aux produits importés qui
représentent 74% des achats des
distributeurs mais aussi à cause des
frais de transport qui sont très
importants naturellement liés à leur
éloignement géographique ces derniers
représentent tout de même 16% du coût
d'un produit pour un distributeur
cookies mécaniquement a des conséquences
sur le porte-monnaie des consommateurs
un seul exemple suffit pour comprendre
la situation à Mayotte le pack d'eau
coûte 9 euros
notons également que l'exiguité des
territoires ultramarins favorisent les
ententes les distributeurs ne sont pas
engagés dans une guerre des prix
comparable à ce qui peut être constaté
en métropole
pour corriger le tir il est urgent
d'adapter un certain nombre de
dispositifs je pense au bouclier qualité
prix qu'il serait pertinent d'élargir un
effort a été fait en décembre 2022
puisque ce bouclier a été étendu à de
nombreux à de nouveaux produits un
effort jugé cependant encore insuffisant
par de nombreux acteurs dont
l'observatoire des prix des marges et
des revenus il me semble aussi que les
lacunes des projets de loi de finances
doivent être comblés si l'on peut
reconnaître que la loi du 16 août 2022
porte en mesure d'urgence pour la
protection du pouvoir d'achat et la loi
du 16 août 2022 de finance rectificative
pour 2022 ont prévu des mesures pour
soutenir le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
ainsi que des mécanismes d'aide aux
collectivités territoriales ceci
s'applique malheureusement de manière
uniforme sur l'ensemble du territoire
national en ne tenant compte que très à
la marge des spécificités des
territoires
notons également que plusieurs
dispositifs d'aides spécifiques aux
outre-mer ont été amputés ou ont tout
simplement disparu je pense à la TVA non
perçue récupérables des entreprises
supprimées pour 100 millions d'euros en
2018 je pense aussi à l'allongement des
cotisations sociales des travailleurs
indépendants diminuer de 40 millions
d'euros à partir de 2018 sans oublier
l'abattement de l'impôt sur le revenu 70
millions avec une visée finale de 400
millions d'euros ou la défiscalisation
passée de 1 milliard en 2011 à moins de
500 millions en 2022
d'après notre collègue Johnny Hajar la
suppression de l'octroi de mer et sont
remplacement par une TVA à 20% serait à
craindre si tel était le cas cela aura
des conséquences désastreuses pour le
développement des collectivités locales
car l'octroi de mer est une ressource
financière pour celle-ci à l'inverse de
la TVA autant de problématiques qu'il
faut considérer en apportant des
réponses sectorisées en fonction des
Outre-mer car chaque territoire
ultramarin est particulier et ne peut se
satisfaire de dispositifs harmonisés en
fait et déconnecté du réel aussi la
création d'une comité d'enquête sur la
vie chère me paraît tout à fait
justifier et je voterai pour tout en
sachant que les difficultés rencontrées
dans certains territoires ultramarins
sont structurels comme à Mayotte qui se
paupérise notamment à cause d'un flux
migratoire incontrôlé je vous remercie
merci madame la députée
la discussion générale est close
je vais maintenant appeler l'article
unique de la proposition de résolution
dans le texte de la commission alors il
y a des inscrits à l'article Monsieur
Christian Baptiste
pour deux minutes maximum
non ça c'est
le micro merci
madame la Présidente chez au collègue le
rapporteur du dia Hajar chez collègues
accéder aux produits de première
nécessité n'est plus une commodité mais
hélas un bien de luxe hors de portée
d'une majorité de nos concitoyens
essentiels se nourrir ce vêtir ou encore
se loger
relève quant à lui du parcours du
combattant en outre je vous ferai
l'économie de factures d'eau
d'électricité de carburant ou encore des
prix des billets d'avion qui ne cesse de
connaître une trajectoire haussière
malheureusement derrière ces allures de
cartes postales les territoires did
outre-mer cachent une toute autre
réalité pour voter précarité chômage
endémique retard structurel abus de
position dominante situations
oligopolistique et j'en passe
honnêtement est-il vraiment utile de
rappeler pour la énième fois à quel
point les populations did une mère
souffre souffre de manque de
considération de mépris de traitement
est juste inéquitable dans cette
république française censée faire de nos
concitoyens ultramarins des citoyens
Français à part entière et non des
citoyens entièrement à part nous avons
espoir qu'avec nos innombrables
interpellations l'État était mise au
fait de la gravité de la situation des
territoires dit d'outre-mer désormais
nous avons besoin d'une instance via
laquelle nous pourrons lancer et
organiser des travaux d'investigation
des travaux qui devront notamment nous
permettre d'identifier les paramètres à
l'origine de la vie chère sur nos
territoires une instance qui se voudrait
très ambitieuse en soi une instance qui
sur la base les travaux seraient aussi
une force de proposition
dans l'unique but que nous puissions
rapidement adresser avec sérieux et
efficacité la problématique systémique
de la vie chère c'est un somme ce que
nous proposons via ce projet de
résolution tendance à la création d'une
commission d'enquête sur le coût de la
vie d'un autre territoire dit
d'outre-mer merci madame la Présidente
Perceval gaillard pour le groupe lfnuck
et pour deux minutes
[Applaudissements]
sur la vie chère
1 2 c'est bon c'est fonctionne merci
madame la Présidente chers collègues
nous ne pouvons que nous réjouir de voir
la question de la vie chère en outre-mer
pleinement abordé dans notre assemblée
nous avons connu beaucoup de débats nous
l'abordons systématiquement dans nos
amendements il y a eu plusieurs missions
d'information de multiples rapports
depuis des années mais à notre
connaissance c'est la première
commission d'enquête donc c'est à part
important qui vient d'être franchi une
commission d'enquête comme vous le savez
détient des pouvoirs importants les
personnes à auditionner sont contraintes
de répondre à la convocation les
rapporteurs sont habilités à se faire
communiquer tous les documents
nécessaires alors investigation la
commission d'enquête que notre vote va
permettre de créer se terminera comme il
se doit par un rapport notre volonté
c'est que ce rapport ne se contente pas
seulement d'identifier mais surtout de
quantifier les facteurs expliquant la
situation de vulnérabilité économique
très forte suivie dans les outre-mer
nous espérons
justement que cette commission d'enquête
permettra de mettre en évidence les
leviers sur lesquels agir pour que les
politiques publiques outre-mer ne se
limitent pas à tenter de combattre des
facteurs de vulnérabilité on le voit
bien ça ne sert pas à grand-chose la vie
est toujours aussi cher mais bien
d'intégrer ces facteurs de vulnérabilité
dans l'ensemble des politiques publiques
menées dans les outre-mer en particulier
la politique des revenus c'est
d'ailleurs la raison de notre amendement
par lequel nous proposons d'élargir le
champ de la commission d'enquête aller
plus loin que le simple costard donné à
cette commission d'enquête la
possibilité de faire un état des lieux
des solutions existantes chers collègues
je vous le dis au regard de la situation
économique et sociale de nos pays au
regard de l'attente dans nos peuples
cette commission ne doit pas ne peut pas
accoucher d'une souris je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Le Fur pour deux minutes que
nous groupe les républicains
et en outre-mer il y a un effet loupe
c'est-à-dire tout est démultiplié tout
est plus compliqué et c'est pour cela
que c'est aussi l'occasion de trouver
des solutions une d'entre elles a été
esquissée par exemple c'est le bouclier
qualité prix mais je constate j'ai été
obligé de le constater en particulier à
la Réunion il y a bien des trous dans
cette raquette du bouclier qualité prix
que certains veulent tendre d'ailleurs à
l'ensemble du territoire national pour
toutes ces raisons je crois qu'il faut
agir qu'il faut faire des propositions
qu'il faut aller au bout des choses mais
tout ça nous engage puisque les
populations sur d'autres en plus
exigeantes que tout aura été mis sur la
table et cela veut dire que le
gouvernement devra en tirer un certain
nombre de conclusions
merci monsieur le député alors nous en
venons
différents amendements à l'article
l'amendement numéro 6 monsieur
rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente c'est juste
un amendement de précision juridique
donc
merci je vais le mettre au bois donc
avec un avis c'est un amendement du
rapporteur favorable qui est pour
qui est contre il est adopté je vous
indique que sur l'ensemble de la
proposition de résolution je suis saisie
par le groupe socialiste apparenté d'une
demande de scrutin public que j'annonce
dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale
maintenant les amendements pouvant faire
l'objet d'une discussion commune avec
tout d'abord des sous amendements alors
le amendement numéro 7 monsieur le
rapporteur qui fait l'objet d'un sous
amendement
numéro 7
donc nous soyons au clair et de façon à
éviter
des oublis on a proposé de modifier
les dromes département région
d'outre-mer et la rédaction porte sur
les collectivités territoriales régies
par les articles 73 et 74 de la
Constitution alors
je tiens à préciser quand même que il y
a une amendement qui était à l'objectif
à l'origine identique de mode petit et
du groupe et notamment du débuté Games
aussi avec mode petit mais on va revenir
dessus plus tard simplement là pour
n'oublier aucune aucun territoire
Ultramar est concerné on propose que la
rédaction change et que l'on précise les
collectivités régies par les articles 73
et 74 de la Constitution merci monsieur
le rapporteur sous amendement numéro 9
madame la Présidente la porte merci
madame la Présidente l'objet du présent
sous amendement c'est d'intégrer aux
champs de compétences de la commission
d'enquête la Nouvelle-Calédonie qui en
est toujours écarté en effet ce
territoire n'est pas au nombre des
collectivités d'outre-mer régies par
l'article 74 de la Constitution dès lors
l'amendement de la commission n'a pas
réellement pour objet d'étendre la
portée du texte à l'ensemble des
territoires ultramarins fort d'une
population de 270 000 habitants
l'archipel de Nouvelle-Calédonie jouit
d'un statut dérogatoire qui lui accorde
une autonomie supérieure ou collectivité
d'outre-mer pour autant il ne nous
semble pas que cette particularité
justifie de ne pas se pencher sur la
question du coût de la vie des néo
calédoniens en effet les mêmes
difficultés se posent en territoire
éloignement et fait de l'insularité
inégalité de qualité des services
publics avec le territoire métropolitain
il y a donc pas de raison selon nous de
mettre la Nouvelle-Calédonie à l'écart
nous vous demandons donc d'adopter ce
sous amendement de bon sens afin
d'éviter cette injustice inutile je vous
remercie merci
alors je ils sont en discussion commune
donc je vais appeler le allemand numéro
2 madame Maud petit
oui merci madame la Présidente comme le
précisait monsieur le rapporteur tout à
l'heure à l'issue de plusieurs
discussions que nous avons eu la semaine
dernière on était convenu de de modifier
la rédaction de votre article pour
intégrer les collectivités d'outre-mer
donc la rédaction que nous proposons
dans cette amendement au nom du modèle
c'était de rajouter simplement dans les
collectivités d'outre-mer régies par
l'article 74 du même texte c'est un
complément à la formulation que vous
aviez faite à l'origine pourquoi parce
que effectivement nous considérons que
même si chaque terre d'outre-mer a sa
spécificité son caractère c'est
différent
ces territoires subissent les mêmes
injustices face à la charte de la vie
en revanche je serai un petit peu du
même avis que vous même si vous n'avez
peut-être pas encore émis votre avis
concernant à l'intégration de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie je pense qu'il y a
une petite difficulté par rapport à ça
mais vous le développerez je pense
monsieur le rapporteur pourquoi parce
que la Nouvelle Calédonie est une
collectivité d'outre-mer à statut
particulier ce qu'on appelle un statut
suis généreux qui résulte de l'Accord de
Nouméa de mai 1998 je pense que à ce
terme même si bien évidemment les
difficultés rencontrées par les
néocalédoniens sont les mêmes que sur
les autres collectivités territoire
d'outre-mer ça me paraît un petit peu
plus compliqué en fait de les intégrer à
la commission d'enquête voilà merci
alors monsieur le rapporteur la vis de
la commission sur le sous amendement
numéro 9
bien c'est avec regret et je conçois que
les problématiques de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie sont les mêmes en
tant que territoire éloignés insulaire
mais la Nouvelle-Calédonie fait partie
de du dispositif de la Constitution au
niveau 13 cela veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'elle a un titre spécial c'est le
titre 13 et les collectivités
ultramarines sont dans le titre 12 du 73
et du 74 c'est une difficulté parce que
on est très éloigné du fond parce que
c'est très différent mais le deuxième
élément qui ferait que je donne qui fait
que je donne un avis défavorable c'est
que la périmètre de la commission est
déjà suffisamment élargi entre le 73 et
le 74 on risque d'affaiblir et on risque
de réduire la portée en termes de
commission d'enquête à vouloir tromper
la rougir donc je donnerai
malheureusement un avis défavorable sur
cette amendement et puis sur le sous
amendement numéro 9
parce que de toutes les façons il faut
que cette commission d'enquête au fond
sur les sujets et réduire ou l'affaiblir
dans son travail en élargissant le
périmètre de trop sur 6 mois parce que
je rappelle que les délais sont pas
allongés ils restent de 6 mois donc plus
on rallonge la charge de travail plus on
va réduire l'efficacité et le rendu de
la commission d'enquête ce n'est pas le
souhait je pense et la volonté de tous
c'est pour ça que je voulais proposer le
retrait ou un avis défavorable et puis
malheureusement et avec regret je le dis
à mon petit j'aurais je souhaite le
retrait parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a
l'initiative de pouvoir regrouper et
élargir le périmètre à l'article de au
collectivités de l'article 64 euros mais
en fait avec les évolutions
institutionnelles passées on se rend
compte qu'il y a des départements des
régions d'outre-mer mais il y a aussi
des collectivités suis génériques comme
la Martinique et la Guyane donc
il faut absolument avoir la rédaction la
plus large et la rédaction qui est
proposée empêche d'intégrer les
collectivités suis généreistes telles
que la Martinique et la Guyane c'est
pour ça que j'aurais malheureusement
mais je tiens à dire et je souligne que
c'est un amendement à la fois de soutien
et de force parce qu'elle est également
d'origine outre-mer et qu'elle porte
dans son cœur l'engagement au niveau des
territoires ultramarins donc je
sollicite son retrait malheureusement
je ne doute pas que notre collègue mon
petit soit sensible une telle
déclaration mais donc le groupe
Renaissance apportera son soutien à
l'amendement du rapporteur et par contre
ne votre a pas de votre acompte sous
amendement et je voudrais expliquer
pourquoi évidemment il faut élargir au
collectivités l'ensemble des
collectivités outre-mer cette démarche
parce que elle est vraie aussi à Wallis
elle est vraie aussi en Polynésie mais
je pense que la situation de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie est différente la
Nouvelle-Calédonie sort d'un processus
où il y a eu le troisième référendum et
l'entrain aussi de convenait ce travail
pour pouvoir bâtir un nouveau statut un
nouveau cadre de vie commune à l'échelle
du territoire ce statut n'est pas qu'un
statut juridique c'est un ancien
ensemble sur des règles de vie sur un
fonctionnement de son économie et les
acteurs sont aujourd'hui en train de
d'échanger c'est compliqué cette
exigeant ça demande beaucoup de rigueur
mais cela veut dire aussi qu'il faut
leur laisser l'initiative de cette
réflexion et c'est pourquoi
je ne pense que ce n'est pas dans le
cadre de cette commission d'enquête nous
devons faire mais dans le 4 dans le
cadre de la construction du futur statut
de Nouvelle-Calédonie qu'il faudra
s'interroger et voir comment il y a
aussi des données économiques intégrer
là-dedans donc contre le sous amendement
alors vous retirez l'amendement madame
mot de petit puis monsieur le député
puis monsieur judo oui merci madame la
Présidente je vais effectivement retirer
la maman du groupe modem parce que le
vôtre est beaucoup mieux rédigé après
coup et je vous remercie quand même
d'avoir rappelé la paternité de cette
réflexion au groupe modem merci et puis
en ce qui concerne la Nouvelle-Calédonie
je veux dire que même si nous
n'intégrions pas
cette collectivité dans la commission
rien n'empêchera que les travaux qui
aboutiront donc à des réflexions et à
des propositions ne puisse servir aussi
à la Nouvelle-Calédonie voilà merci
madame la députée
merci Madame Présidente je voudrais
intervenir pour relever le caractère
absurde juridiquement intenable de ce
que vous dites enfin vous nous faites du
juridisme de base en disant
un statut particulier l'autre collègue
parle du référendum qui n'a absolument
rien à voir avec la vie chère je suis
extrêmement scandalisé franchement par
votre refus d'intégrer la
Nouvelle-Calédonie qui dans dans un
commission d'enquête je sais pas si vous
êtes déjà allé moi j'y vais souvent j'ai
ta famille ce que vous avez décrit à la
tribune ou sur les bancs en matière de
vie chère se retrouve parfaitement une
lettre Calédonie donc et donc il est
absolument invraisemblable
il est invraisemblable que sur le fond
parlait du fond le fond c'est la vie
chère c'est pas du juridisme c'est pas
le référendum ça n'a rien à voir il est
invraisemblable que la
Nouvelle-Calédonie soit exclue de la
commission d'enquête c'est indépendable
je peux vous assurer que si ceci est
voté les nouvelles caldoniens seront ou
sans leurs amis dans ce dans sa
démystique merci
alors je vais mettre au roi le sous
amendement numéro 9 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable du rapporteur qui est pour
qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté le jeu maison vois
l'amendement numéro 7 du rapporteur qui
est pour
qui est contre il est adopté le numéro 2
a été retiré amendement numéro 5
monsieur le rapporteur
rédactionnel
non c'est un amendement d'abord initié
par le collègue maintenant donc je
souhaite rendre à César ce qui lui
appartient c'est pas parce qu'il y a mon
nom dessus et mais effectivement bon là
maintenant tu es satisfait mais j'ai
souhaité quand même donner lui donner
raison en commission et donc cet
amendement là a été validé de façon à
dans la rédaction de la création de la
commission d'enquête sur le coût de la
vie d'intégrer la question pas
simplement du diagnostic mais aussi et
surtout des préconisations et des
solutions à mettre en place voilà
merci monsieur le rapporteur madame la
Présidente panneau
du coup madame la Présidente d'abord un
mot évidemment pour remercier le groupe
socialiste et le collègue Hajar pour
avoir proposé cette commission d'enquête
et je voudrais insister sur l'amendement
qui est présenté actuellement sur la
question des solutions parce que les
territoires did outremer sont aux
avant-postes de notre République sur
beaucoup des aspects évidemment ils sont
aux avant-postes sur la question du
dérèglement climatique puisqu'il
subissent en premier lieu
l'intensification et la multiplication
des événements climatiques extrêmes
évidemment ils sont en première ligne
aussi sur la question de l'eau sur
lequel nous avons mené avec plusieurs
collègues ici de longs combats pour le
droit à l'eau pour toutes et tous et je
et ils sont en première ligne sur la
question de la pauvreté sur la question
du chômage sur la question de la vie
chère et ces questions des solutions
sont très importantes parce que ce que
subissent nos compatriotes d'outre-mer
avec ce que cela implique en termes
d'injustice en prendre des souffrances
se vit aussi en hexagone et de manière
de plus en plus forte lorsque 117
communes ont été privées d'eau cet été
lorsque là aussi la vie chère est vécue
aujourd'hui avec la crise que nous
vivons et que je le dis non pas pour
comparer les choses mais pour dire que
les solutions qui seront apportées dans
les dans cette commission d'enquête sont
des solutions qui je l'espère et
clairont l'ensemble de la nation et
aideront pour l'égalité de toutes et
tous dans nos pays c'est pour ça que les
territoires d'outre-mer sont aux
avant-postes de notre République il peut
être ils peuvent être avant-postes de ce
que nous devons faire sur le droit à
l'eau sur le droit à la dignité pour
toutes et tous et j'espère que avec ces
travaux enfin les profiteurs de crise
tremblr trembleront un peu merci madame
la Présidente je vais mettre en voix cet
amendement numéro 5 du rapporteur qui
est pour
qui est contre il est adopté
alors j'ai reçu deux demandes
d'explication de vote madame Karine
Lebon pour le groupe GDR
ah pardon excusez-moi il y a un
amendement au titre que je n'ai pas
excusez-moi pardon alors je vais faire
excusez-moi madame la députée il y a un
amendement au titre l'amendement numéro
c'est un amendement sur le titre de la
proposition de résolution c'est
l'amendement numéro 8
du rapporteur
c'est toujours pour réintégrer les
collectivités de l'article 73 et 74 dans
la rédaction simplement
et alors je donc et à ce il y a un sous
amendement qui a été déposé à cette
amendement sur le titre pour lequel je
suis saisie par le groupe rassemblement
national d'une demande de scrutin public
que j'annonce dans l'enceinte de
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale
donc pour le sous-amendement numéro 10
madame la Présidente je vous remercie il
s'agit encore une fois d'inclure la
Nouvelle-Calédonie qui écartait sans
raison de cette proposition de
résolution dans sa rédaction actuelle on
va voir ainsi par ce vote qui prime
vraiment et cela Nouvelle-Calédonie ou
plutôt votre sectarisme je vous remercie
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
je ne donnais pas d'importance aux
qualificatifs employés par certains
de ceux qui portent
ce sous amendement
je pense simplement que
je pense simplement que nous ne sommes
pas dans un théâtre
et que
je ne cherche pas à opposer
les collectivités ultramarines
et je ne souhaite pas je ne souhaite pas
véritablement que l'on puisse et
j'insiste ne pas affaiblir le travail et
le contenu pour les
ultramarins
issus du 73 et du 74 par contre comme il
faut permettre à ce que chacun puisse
s'y retrouver je vous invite puisque
nous avons tous un droit de tirage pour
les commissions d'enquête
ayant un titre spécial sur la nouvelle
Denis rien n'empêche qu'il y a une
demande spécifique qui soit faite de
façon à ce que l'on puisse être le plus
productif et optimisé le travail sans
que aucun territoire ultramarin ne soit
oublié donc ce sera de toutes les façons
et
je le répète soit une demande de retrait
soit un avis défavorable pour soutenir
l'ensemble des territoires du 73 74
aujourd'hui qui sont dans le même titre
12 de la Constitution et pas dans un
titre différent spécialisé pour éviter
le grand écart merci monsieur le
rapporteur alors je vais mettre aux voix
par un scrutin public le sous amendement
numéro 10 qui a reçu un avis défavorable
du de la commission le scrutin est
ouvert
[Musique]
le scrutin est clos
183 votants exprimés 178 majorité 90
pour 43 contre 135 Assemblée nationale
n'a pas adopté et je mettre au voile
amendement numéro 8 du rapporteur sur le
changement de titre qui est pour
qui est contre il est adopté maintenant
nous en passons aux explications de vote
que j'ai reçu madame Karine Lebon pour
le groupe GDR
pour deux minutes maximum merci madame
la Présidente chers collègues le
chanteur Thierry Gauliris du groupe
Basse-Terre chantait le morceau mon
liberté dans lequel il disait quand moi
elle était petite moitié misère zordi
moi les sommaires quand j'étais petit je
vivais dans la misère aujourd'hui je
suis chômeur cet état de fait qui soit
en 1993 comme dans cette chanson ou
aujourd'hui encore dans notre île à la
réunion n'est pas bien différent il est
facile très facile de nous demander à
nous ultramarins d'aimer la République
alors même que celle-ci malgré l'amour
qu'on lui porte nous nous le rend que
très rarement j'attire votre attention
chers collègues sur l'absence
révélatrice de membres de gouvernement
sur ses bancs même s'il y avait il est
vrai qu'il n'y a pas d'obligation mais
cela dénote un désintérêt qui est
choquant
nos concitoyens
ultramarins ont du mal du mal à entendre
les paroles moralisatrices du
gouvernement d'un pays qui lorsque nous
demandons le droit à la différence nous
reprend en criant tout haut tout fort
les valeurs de l'égalité par rapport à
l'Hexagone mais qui en même temps
lorsque nous réclamons le droit à
l'égalité de revenir de prix de
traitement nous justifient la différence
par notre éloignement pour rappel et ce
hors inflation les prix de l'alimentaire
entre l'hexagone et la Réunion
connaissent un écart de plus de 28% au
détriment de notre île notre France ne
serait-elle pas si une et indivisible
qu'on le prétend n'avons-nous dans des
mythes que notre pauvreté et nos
problèmes chers collègues ces inégalités
sont à la base même du manque de
confiance et de la déconnexion de nos
populations envers notre République la
création de cette commission d'enquête
chargée d'étudier d'évaluer l'ensemble
des mécanismes qui concourent au coût de
la vie dans les départements et régions
d'outre-mer est alors une nécessité nous
voterons en faveur de ce texte
merci madame la députée
pour le groupe yacht et pour deux
minutes maximum très bien merci même la
Présidente chers collègues tout d'abord
vous remercier remercier
monsieur le rapporteur et les
socialistes pour cette proposition de
commission d'enquête sur les coups de la
vie chère que nous savons très
les causes sont très multiples et ça a
été évoqué par l'ensemble de nos
collègues ce matin nous avons les coups
de transport et de logistique pour
acheminer les produits qui entraînent
des prix très élevés quoi que vous le
disiez ou quoi que vous pensiez sur
certains de ces bancs et de plus le peu
de concurrence laisse une opacité à
peine voilée des marges parfois abusives
ça aussi il nous faudra également voir
étudier et l'amendement proposé par le
rapporteur Hajar et proposer également
par le député Ratenon va nous permettre
par exemple de pouvoir mettre en
application une préconisation de
l'Autorité de la concurrence par la
création d'une centrale d'achat
régionalisé qui permettrait aux petits
commerces et à certains particuliers
d'accéder pardon qui permettrait de de
pouvoir créer une centrale d'achat sous
forme de société coopérative à collectif
avec l'appui des collectivités locales
mais également de l'état des
consommateurs et des commerçants ça ne
doit pas être vu comme une
alternative obqp mais vraiment une la
possibilité de lutter contre la vie
chère et permettre aux petits
commerçants de se concentrer sur des
produits à prix très compétitif donc
nous voterons bien sûr pour aider demain
pour cette proposition
je vous remercie
merci
aucune voix de doigt manqué ce matin
pour voter cette proposition de
résolution vuité
qui c'est qui a pris la parole je vous
laisserai bien vite la parole
pas de surprise dans cette prise de
parole évidemment nous voterons c'est
très résolution juste pour regretter il
n'y a pas de faux procès ni de procès
d'attention à faire le ministre des
Outre-mer est au Sénat en ce moment les
exécutif donné aucun indicatif sur cette
résolution et la majorité est là pour la
soutenir écoutez maintenant ce qu'il
faut c'est travailler pour réussir à
résoudre les problèmes et pas trop ses
intentions donc votre rond pour la
résolution merci Monsieur le
député
mes chers collègues aucune voix ne doit
manquer ce matin pour voter cette
proposition de résolution aucune voie ne
peut manquer tout d'abord nous tenons à
saluer comme ça déjà été dit
l'initiative prise par les camarades du
groupe socialiste d'inscrire dans leur
niche cette proposition de résolution
comme cela a été dit aussi beaucoup de
rapports de missions d'information déjà
été faits sur la question de la vie
chère nous connaissons la réalité de nos
pays ce que nous attendons ce que nos
peuples attendent c'est de contraindre
les acteurs privés qui profitent de leur
situation monopolistique et
oligopolistique à la transparence
cela était dit si la France est une
puissance maritime si la France est une
puissance spatiale si la France abrite
10% de la diversité mondiale c'est grâce
aux outre-mer la République française ne
peut pas faire comme s'il n'y avait pas
de peuple qui vivait sur ces territoires
alors mes chers collègues très
simplement voter cette résolution
aidez-nous dans notre combat au
quotidien contre la vie chère dans nos
territoires notre groupe la France
insoumise votre a ce texte je vous
remercie merci monsieur le député la
parole est à Madame Maud petit
oui merci madame la Présidente
simplement quelques mots soulignés à
nouveau l'intérêt que nous avons tous
pour la proposition de notre collègue
Johnny Hajar que je remercie encore une
fois au nom du groupe modem et puis
simplement rappeler aussi voilà avec
quelques mots de bienveillance que nous
sommes tous d'accord aujourd'hui sur ces
bancs pour avancer ensemble et
intelligemment à trouver des solutions
pour lutter contre la charte et de la
vie dans nos territoires et
collectivités d'outre-mer et donc je le
rappelle le modem votera donc cette PPR
le modem comme la majorité tout entière
prendra pleinement part en conscience et
en responsabilité je vous remercie merci
madame l'indéputée je vais maintenant
mettre au voile la proposition de
résolution je vous invite à regagner
votre place puisqu'il y a un scrutin
public que j'ai annoncé tout à l'heure
dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
votant 263 exprimés 263 majorités 132
pour 263 contre 0 l'Assemblée nationale
a adopté
[Applaudissements]